okay sounds I betcha at your bar
psychobabble
and replying Darkwood a scary-ass game
and we're much about this game other
than it's [ __ ] terrifying
it's but apparently really good game no
jump scares actually it's real terror so
let's just let's just jump read into it
okay burp I won that one
don't mind if I do difficulty normal and
they go go
I think I did once hey did anyone know
you're pretty equipment skip prologue
yeah yes alright let's do this let's do
this
you're playing a challenging unforgiving
game you want happy led by the hand
respect the woods be patient for skin
all right we got this brows we got this
antidote what's I'm an Eagle Scout am I
not saying I'm safe my Boy Scout
training has done this Glenny
I think it's lighting I try to think
about these things I think it's letting
okay Kevin uh tea apple probably all
right let's do this
oh my god I think gradient effect
I see hatred and fear and their eyes are
they talking about who was that
they say that guy right there hey looks
pretty gross
I said five responsible for the
spreading disease yeah it would be
really bad how that sorry
but at that cigarette as if I were the
source of all the misery plaguing this
land okay please pretty dark so far
I have never a had from them never to
run the woods have closed us off from
the outside around though yeah I get it
they got so no Walmart I guess NA name
wasn't prime need price on Amazon just
my name's uh prime we're all doomed
ok you get it you get it there is me and
kindest uh-huh made device mannequin
it's a yeah they said I spur hard I
don't want to read him no I'll take
these pills that might I find out no get
away
there's the generators on banana juice
camera useless medical bag Oh down there
[ __ ] is that ok
okay just uh there empty rack what is
that over there
good scaring use this junk in here
he could only my bad [ __ ] up radio
huh yeah boy [ __ ] through the static no
you can't dump it crazy
barricaded went down [ __ ] [ __ ] laugh
okay Manica buck
okay hey that one that's for sure
subscribe everything for now turn this
up just this to conserve energy uh how
about a Bell Tolls I've been sterilized
this Christian living here for a while
how's that over there
yeah okay okay
look Terry can I help you I should know
that that I say yeah it's disgusting and
it's that Eddie Rock
a actor yes
Saxe right then I ground the weapons
left it in your hotbar holds right mouse
button take aim anyway [ __ ] half our
Oh dead cow what am I supposed to be
doing shifter run and this happen I
should be dealing around here
I think it was supposed to be that's
like fortifying okay here's the map some
more discover curling red okay
so what's up devoured all the routes no
one's able to go through this thicket
and there's something I should be doing
around there
well I'm sure what is that can I help
you sir hold up control or left shift
okay I should pass the torch crap thing
menu
that's freaking dark is this
how far should I be going this is the
house that bandit has placed [ __ ]
sucks
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on here
yeah there's a big complete it was all
right close how about my start there
what [ __ ] I can't tell what time of
this well I'm basically at the end how
long this torch go for hey sir can I
help you sir
okay hey is this guy no it's a star it
conjures never see him around here
before
okay but he got the K because a 21 and
I'm very interested and knowing what
that 21 is let's think I'm back on stay
coming she managed to sneak in here he
shouldn't have I get out okay
that's Salim up a bang of course um I
get it but that and I wish you have a
bang and our show is up no importance
mmm I've said it better myself you know
I'd say
I need to get out of this accursed
forest not Tommy wait in our batch yeah
I'm a rat
yeah me shut my hand oh I'll let ya go
I sometimes hear have us is that Jessica
Simpson just calling Mike hey Spence I'm
mad for a walk in killing right through
a time where as they exit time I bet
damning what town batch can i wet
yeah smack him again alright zags a
[ __ ]
where's the exit time my bench I carry
your dog if I have depth ain't at the
trip change this hey saw it's fine yet
and I forgot my mare I guess had that
hello say can I help you
getting out [ __ ] stomachache wait what
the [ __ ] so I'm playing this kind out
they're strong dismantle I have a
lockpick yeah yeah
a lockpick
okay you're strong to this mantel
Oh Sarah you wonder if I can use a
shovel
oh yeah I'm breaking through this bad
boy that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where do you go
sir better I loo the house a night it's
safer here dismantled hey [ __ ] as they
do a repair
it turns it off
don't [ __ ] that nice dismantle wind
down blocking this oh yeah okay what's
in here like a table nothing Eric any
window of course that's in here steady
leg
it's like
gets lien tank finished out generators
doubt
oh [ __ ] is that right
there's that
oh [ __ ]
they [ __ ] that [ __ ] is it yeah yeah
thank you for eight nine - okay for a
four eight nine step
you heard of [ __ ] apply some force to
it
have my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
scared of chamois get [ __ ] way got him
oh [ __ ] that scared too shabby yes
yeah Pakistan
[Applause]
howling [ __ ]
rap that's one scary [ __ ] that's a
monster
oh [ __ ]
how does that been as good as Hodgins
you were done without your music oh I
thought you're finished I guess you're
not I guess you've never quite finished
[Music]
[Music]
well good to see what's in chat with
that guy on that there thanks for
watching yeah see ya in the next one
yeah